lo más importante que tiene perú está en
el banco de suplentes que ricardo gareca
al hombre que de alguna manera le hizo
una reingeniería al fútbol peruano para
poderlo llevar a la copa del mundo hace
cuatro años en el 2018 pero uno jugado
mundial desde 1980 en aquella generación
dorada de oblitas equipo que incluso
estuvo en las semifinales con otros
futbolistas del mundial del 9 en la
segunda ronda mejor del mundial de 1970
ganó la copa américa del 70 y 50 y
colombia y después de ese mundial del 70
al 78 y del 82 había dejado ir a los
mundiales pero claramente gareca es el
hombre que está detrás del éxito del
fútbol peruano con hombres como hoy
yoshimar yotún un hombre muy importante
en el fútbol de méjico también cueva
trauco pero para mí el hombre más
importante renato tapia un hombre criado
en el sur europeo en holanda es el
casemiro para que quienes no lo tienen
en cuenta es el que hace miro del celta
de vigo el equipo del norte de españa
el equipo que dirige el chacho coudet se
ha hecho muy importante allí es un
hombre que está sobre los 25 millones de
euros puede salir en este mercado de
contrataciones y aquel gol que ha
conseguido perú
con la salida de paulo guerrero ha
aparecido gianluca la padula un hombre
de origen peruano que tuvo algunos
partidos con él italiana no se pudo
consolidar lo encontraron en el
benevento un equipo que juega entre la
serie b y la sería e incluso la padula
marcado y el primer gol en ese partido
ante paraguay hay que dar un dato
adicional si el partido es contra
australia la última vez que se
enfrentaron fue en el mundial del 2018 y
fue la única victoria que consiguió perú
en ese mundial en un grupo en el que
además estaban francia y dinamarca ese
antecedente favorece al equipo peruano
que tiene como gran insignia y como gran
representante un argentino ricardo
gareca que incluso rodri había dirigido
allí a universitario de deportes conocía
el medio peruano algo que también le
sirvió al ex jugador del américa de cali
en sus épocas de futbolista aquí en
colombia para hacerse cargo de la
selección peruana